hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and I'm Kurt email chair and this is
Tamara just saw and Cody also just saw
two as well dead Lili
the movie the American movie who has
just been crushing it Netflix is a God
among movie places I guess I was
expecting to go into this and enjoy it
and then write reviews came out right
and then I was like well maybe I still
will because I like things so like maybe
all like sure there no that was yeah I
was past hero
you were you were expect that you were
hoping for a daredevil season one and
then you were like maybe it's gonna be a
daredevil season two and then it turned
out to just be a fist yes so it was bad
so four cameras never seen I did def
note the live action movie and then the
first 10 episodes of the anime I know
the gist of some of the details I know
like kind of what happens I was not even
mad that this was so far from the actual
story of Death Note that has been told
to us before and that people have loved
I just know that it was a terrible movie
like it's just a bad movie it was like a
cross between like what if the Disney
Channel original movie was also a
Tarantino movie and or the Twilight
movie meets final destination I feel
like that I feel like that was the pitch
idle hands very idle handsy but not as
good which is saying like I was not a
huge idle hands fan save your emails
they were trying too hard to make it
like a horror film which if they had
gone like into that identical but like
real like a weird scary demon but in
this like Disney Channel original movie
setting right
just kind of comical bit right no what I
said at Amer was and I got I got a lot
of like Return to Oz vibes like a
scarecrow specifically in returned Oz
very much what were you feels like also
I've seen that I oh I love don't return
to Oz I used to rent that every summer
because I'm a look at I'm a sad little
little French boy oh this little parasol
curl up and watch Return to Oz and have
a weird crush on the Scarecrow it was a
it was a long day oh but wait I hate it
just just 100% of my hate in my body was
just towards the girl she was the yeah I
hated both of them me and more but both
of them like light is not good and so
like we said like different from the
anime for sure right he's insufferable
for a different reason so light in the
anime is insufferable because like that
kid that was so pretentious you're just
like we get it the Netflix version he's
just like annoying like loner hipster
kid that's like cool that's great it was
set in Seattle it was very Seattle it
could have been okay but the character
blights
if they hadn't skipped over every single
character building moment they could
have ever skipped over chapter one he
hasn't killed anyone chapter two he's
still four hundred people and they've
skipped over all the character
development and all the character
relationship with his girlfriend it's
like if girlfriend goes from like creepy
to just full-on Manson family vibe but
to the point where she's like oh well
let's kill your dad that's the obvious
you know he no hesitation and no
explanation then writes his name in the
book just like crazy things that just
don't know no rationality I did like a
yeah
down L was cool I kept saying like I
would watch like a you know like a
Marvel of Marvel Netflix L series where
it's just like L solving crimes that are
like super weird anytime people have
commented on the tamarins never seen
episode that I did or like talked to me
about Death Note it's that L is the true
star like character of the series is
just like the most well-written one the
most engaging those interesting and that
still holds up here the actor was great
yes did a really good job of capturing L
from the anime I feel like with the eyes
and she's like the kind of toned out
like kind of a demeanor but like also
his own saying like it was a it was a
good mix it was a good I really like oh
yeah he definitely was the David s
Pumpkins of this movie it was his own
thing yeah so like you said people
talking to me about that no as if that
like happens on the street like hey you
what are your thoughts like that the
detective Turner is fine
because he plays a cop well like that's
not really an exciting character but
yeah other than that l Matar he's good
but right but yeah I the end is supposed
to be this giant shock where you're like
blown away and it's like unraveling what
he's planned all along it's like it's
it's not a shock it's not interesting
and it's not it's so ladies just very
typical like oh let me reveal my plan
that I've set up and and also it he
hasn't been that like with light in the
animate he's like he is smart even
though he's incredibly pretentious he is
actually still relatively good at
planning this kid has shown none of that
and then suddenly it's like here's my
mastermind plan that I'm gonna tell my
father after he discovers I'm a serial
killer and then it's not wrapped up it
all those hints that there could be a
second if it had gone well Netflix is
obviously gonna be like what just
kidding not excited one of this well I
mean yeah but it's just it just feels
lazy it feels very like I've seen this a
million times
it wasn't believable because the
character of Aldous wasn't that cunning
the whole movies yeah and it was none of
the pale like it's just the end it was
just like I don't care at all I do not
care about this yeah we both kept losing
interest pretty regularly if yeah I just
felt like a bad like which is really out
of town for for Netflix right it looks
just such a good job right there
especially original things this was it
that this felt like what I was expecting
the Dark Tower to be from the reviews
like this felt literally thinking about
while watching yeah this felt like a
movie that was entirely made by
producers in a room and no writers right
well we got make it all about a love
interest we got like which also made it
so Chloe annoying that the whole thing
is based off this weird body and Klein
sadistic serial killer thing with no
chemistry yeah like I have imagined them
to like you know I like make each other
believe in and make out in it like there
are so many times where it's so creepy
weird and not in like a and not an
interesting point was not weird to say
but like there was it creepy interesting
it was just creepy dumb because outside
of those moments they weren't like that
as a character so it was just these like
weird like Oh work and then you see in
the edges lockers as normal people scare
me and it's like oh okay
well you're just that's well your soul
energy actor like the guy who plays
light I think it's a is a decent actor
in like kind of feel-good movies yeah
and John Green stuff yeah which I enjoy
those films sure but this was not
enjoyable I wonder if that's him I
wonder if it's probably mostly how it
was written a combination of the two a
little bit of column a a little bit of
column B right Oh purring his yeah this
was on there that was great that was my
favorite part of the entire movie was if
you watching with subtitles at one point
it just says purring hiss for speaking
of for one of the noises ryuko mates
come on over that's already better than
the whole soundtrack I will say one of
my points are confuse
with Death Note in general is the
approximation that you have to get with
the names because alright it's already
been proven that you can't use nicknames
or code names right because you couldn't
use L you get different L and look in
his face and go L face hello real name
okay so like what if so like where does
that cut off like if my name is Michael
but I go by Mike do you have to write
Michael yeah if he's for my name wrong
like if my name is Sarah but I felt with
an with an H you write it sa ra is that
wrong
what's the approximation if you're
trying to kill the artist formerly known
as Prince do you have to figure out what
his name is
can you call him Prince can you call him
the artist formerly known as Prince do
you have to draw the symbol with the
little trumpet what are we doing that
was too soon on Prince but will you rate
this I rated 3 plaid shirts out of 400
murders I think probably four terrible
high school relationships out of out of
that good college relationship you get
but I deeply apologize to at the humans
who enjoy this anime and who were just
really bummed about this film
next week we watch it and I am so
excited they've already told the people
I can only watch it on a phone in a
brightly lit field I'll take care of
Cody make sure he's fine
[Music]